you said you had three fights left in
your contract yeah how do you see those
playing out fighting in uh obviously
fighting in december paiva i would love
to fight yanez february march and then i
have one more fight on the contract um
april may probably june july cody
garbrandt could be he's he's gone
but we'll see where how this fight plays
out with kai kar france he's got to win
this fight
he'll be like one in 37 if he loses he's
got to win this [ __ ] fight like he's
has to win this fight um kykar france
hasn't been winning everything i'm not
sure about i know of the name car
friends but i'm not sure he's the only
cat from um
from addison
yeah i couldn't tell you who he fought
ever like i know his name i just don't
know who he's fought uh i don't know if
he's not a winning record you see i
don't know i don't know anything about
him um but yeah cody's got to win this
fight he's got to like he i mean
he goes that's really cool man
you know like i bring up all joe and
bring up cody and uh you're
just
evidently supportive of these
competitors yeah and i think like with
the cody thing it's like if you lose i
would like to fight cody someday i think
it'd be a massive fight like i'm in the
business i won't put on massive fights
me and cody
if he wins and keeps winning like we
could be a pay-per-view me and peter
young could be a massive pay-per-view me
and cory like we can there's all these
guys could be massive pay-per-views if
we all just keep winning so yeah i want
cody to go out there and win he's got a
name already it's like me and kai kar
francine's in the pay-per-view like me
and cody could be a massive pay-per-view
so it's like these guys
i want to see them win so i can fight
them and it makes sense you know
i like that dude and like i said i don't
take anything personally and cody about
beef on twitter and stuff and it's like
it's entertainment beef but it's also
like he he does he probably takes it
personal too maybe like cheeto or maybe
they don't maybe they see it like man
like it's entertainment like but uh for
i mean he's gonna be at the hotel same
same as me fight week so it's like we
you see if it's personal to them like
interesting elevator rides yeah
ufc does a good job putting like because
they bought the whole [ __ ] hotel they
bought a hotel for f for vegas so they
do a good job putting people like not
next to each other
right yeah and who's who's cody fighting
kai car france oh dad i'm kid of course
yeah yeah all right at 125. so it's his
debut at 25. yeah but we're just 125.
exactly it's it's what's that like 25
yeah why
why wouldn't you fight up like why would
you want to deal with the weight cut
because
it's very big he probably walks around i
think he's 150 148 149 which is like if
you walk around that way you could make
125. but why wouldn't you why would you
want to go through a weight cut why
wouldn't you want to just
chill cody's chin is an issue you know
like you can't get knocked out like that
and then if you look at when when tj
came down to flyweight like [ __ ] he
did not bring his chin with him
i think cody's chin i don't think it's
too
i think like the shots that he ate from
tj both times
tj was cheating he's on epo
allegedly i don't know like in those
fights
which is a huge advantage it's like hard
to judge his chin off that pedro munoz
hits hard knocked him out too but then
he just fought rob
five five minute rounds ate some clean
shots didn't get knocked out um got his
ass kicked rob font who was a [ __ ]
stud who's kind of under the radar not
like a super popular fighter but a
[ __ ] stud boxing super super slick
boxing man beat his ass beat cody's ass
i re-watched that fight the other day
and cody's he's got a chin he [ __ ]
ate some big shots um
so yeah i don't think going down to 25
is going to be good for his chin though
when you cut weight like that you lose
brain fluid and brain fluid takes the
longest to hydrate from and we get about
20
i don't know 30 hours or whatever it is
to rehydrate which who knows if that's
really enough time to
get that brain pulled back especially
for cody but i don't know if kai kar
france is like a knockout guy but still
in those little gloves it only takes
[ __ ]
one little shot dude yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude